linking animations to our scroll
position on a page has never been easier
thanks to the web animations api and
scroll timeline making animations like
this one a breeze
hello my friend and friends thank you so
much for coming to join me once again
and if you're new here my name is kevin
and here at my channel i hope you fall
madly deeply in love with css but today
we're taking a bit of a different path
because we're actually going to be
exploring some javascript over on my
discord it was suggested that i take a
look at making scroll-based animations
and with how easy it is to do with the
web animations api and scroll timeline
now it seemed like a really good time to
jump in and take a look at that first
we're going to do a very simple thing
which you see all over the place which
is the scroll position trackers that go
across the top of a page just to
understand a little bit on how all of
this works and then we're going to step
things up and explore a little bit more
of what we can do by making those images
that can slide in and appear and really
do anything you want with those types of
things all right so as you can see i've
already written some html here but it's
just a whole bunch of content basically
and i've put a couple of pictures in
here that we can play with and it's from
the site actually it's the same image
that was asked if i could recreate this
with
but yeah we're gonna do one extra line
of html here just to get things started
so i'm gonna do a div of scroll tracker
just like that and we're just gonna
leave it blank with that div in place
this is just really for decorative
purposes but let's come over to here and
we're gonna do my scroll tracker
and we're going to let's start by giving
this a height um
we'll say 0.5 ram we'll give it a
background color and that could be i
have some variables set up so i'm just
going to color primary 400 which should
give it a blue color and there it is
but we do want to do
one more thing with this
let's give this a position
of fixed and the reason i'm doing
position fixed is because when i scroll
i want to make sure that it always stays
in view
and because i'm going to put a position
fixed on this this position fixed will
actually make right now the default
width is 100 it's going to shrink down
to zero so if i hit save it seems to
vanish we could just give it a width of
a hundred percent uh but what i'm going
to say is inset because i wanna set a
top of zero anyway so i'm gonna do an
inset of zero zero auto and inset is a
shorthand for top bottom left and right
and so this is my top and it's like
margin so with three properties that
would be my left and my right and then
the auto of zero just means sort of
ignore the bottom property almost
and there we go we get my scroll tracker
that's there but obviously we want this
to actually track our position now
interesting this is something that i did
recently with css only using scroll
timeline and what we're looking at today
is actually built on the same technology
that makes the scroll timeline possible
the only issue is scroll timeline right
now has basically no support other than
like on the cutting edge browsers and
behind flags and things like that which
isn't very realistic and so this is very
similar in how it functions though we're
going to be doing everything in
javascript and even on the javascript
side the support isn't fantastic but we
have a polyfill that we're going to be
able to use so the first thing i'm going
to do is actually just paste in the link
to the polyfill here so i'm just
importing this
directly and i'll put a link to this
polyfill there which has a little bit
more information on how you could use it
within your projects but for a simple
demo like this just importing it at the
top of my javascript is perfect though
if we do want to bring it in as an
import statement like this this does
have to be a module so luckily it's easy
enough to do you just come into here and
you can write type is equal to module
and just to show you if i hit save now
nothing should be a problem let's go
look in our console
uh there's no errors if actually let's
not go there let's save this file too
if i come here and i remove the type
equals module you'll see that i we get a
syntax error so just if you want to have
that import statement at the top um just
make sure you have that so that it can
work
and so let's close that and we can jump
back on over into our javascript all
right and now we get to jump into the
fun bits and if you follow me you might
not be doing a lot of javascript so if
that's the case i will try and take
things slow enough because even for me
javascript isn't
always the most comfortable thing in the
world at least compared to css
so first i'm going to make a constant
scroll tracker just so we can have you
know we need to tell it what we're going
to be playing with here so let's do a
document.uh query selector
and on the query selector that is going
to be for my
scroll
tracker
right that should do that the trick on
that one and then we want to use this
somehow so before we do anything with
the scroll tracker what i'm going to do
is actually because we will be writing a
bit of javascript it does take up more
room than css so let's make that a
little bigger and the first thing we
want to do i'm going to create a
constant and i'm going to call this
scroll tracking time line the name of it
is whatever you want to name it here but
what's important here is that we use a
new and it's going to be a capital s
scroll time
line and then we're going to have an
object so i'm going to open and close my
curly braces and inside of there we have
a few different things that we can
define
in this case we're actually going to be
sticking with the defaults but i'm still
going to show the different options that
we have here so you have a source and by
default the source is the entire
viewport because that's your scrolling
element if you wanted to do this within
a different element that does scroll
this has to be something that scrolls so
if you wanted to do something different
that scrolls you could list out the
source here what this actually is we're
new document.scrolling
element
another one that we can have here is our
orientation orientation and we have
block or inline so do you want it to be
block is going to be up and down
scrolling and if you wanted to look for
uh inline so left to right scrolling or
horizontal scrolling you could just
switch that there
and the last thing we're going to do is
what's the range that we're actually
looking at now for that range it's
called scroll
offsets and the scroll offsets we're
going to have to tell it the starting
point and the ending point and for this
you just put it inside your square
brackets and there's different ways we
can do this i'm going to do capital all
capital css dot percent
and put a zero and then we'll put a
comma and then do css.percent
and do 100. so we're checking from zero
all the way to 100 but we'll sort of
look at what this does a little bit in a
second
the problem right now is we've set this
up we have a scroll timeline so it's
going to be paying attention to our
scrolling from the top all the way down
to the bottom of our page looking at the
block orientation and again of the
entire document and these two again we
could actually omit those and it should
work just fine but we're looking at a
demo so i'll leave those on there but
what we need to do now is we actually
have to use this somewhere to actually
get this to work so to do that we want
to attach it to our scroll tracker that
we have right here so for this we're
going to do scroll tracker tracker come
on there we go uh dot animate nice and
easy and we're gonna come in here i'm
gonna push return and then open and
close some curly braces because we have
a couple of different objects that we're
going to be working on here and inside
this first one what we want to do is say
what we're actually going to be
animating what are the properties we're
doing so the first property um and with
a tracker like this you could be
animating the width you could also be
doing
if we'd set this up a little bit
differently we could animate the whip if
you wanted to do it by using your left
and your rights whatever it is because
it's a scroll based animation i don't
know actually what the implications are
of animating things that normally we'd
be a little bit more concerned about so
that's something to look into but i
think like the idea of like a buttery
smooth animation might be a bit less
important here since it's really linked
to your scrolling positions
um but what we're going to do for this
one is i'm just going to do a tran i'm
going to say we're going to animate our
transform property
and then we're going to open and close
square brackets and i want to tell it
what we're and a little bit like we did
with our scroll offsets we're going to
say what the beginning transform is and
what the end transform is
so here we're going to say scale x of 0
and then i'm going to put scale
x and i made a mistake here of
1. and the mistake for that is you just
want to make sure that these are wrapped
inside of parentheses not parenthesis of
uh quotations so there we go and so
that's set up now we as i said we will
have multiple objects here so i'm going
to do a comma and we're going to open
and close another set of curly braces
and inside this one it might seem a
little bit silly but you're going to
need a duration now this animate is not
part of only the scroll timeline that
we're looking at which is right here the
new scroll timeline this is part of the
web animations api so durations here
could be used for other things it's not
necessarily to link it to scroll based
animations and just know it's always in
milliseconds as you would expect with
javascript but really the duration has
no impact here since we're going to be
linking it but we're going to throw one
on there anyway uh and the other thing
we want is to say what the timeline is
and in this case it's my scroll tracking
timeline that we created right here and
with that we should be good to go except
i think block here actually needs to be
inside quotation marks as well i do
apologize for that let's hit save and
it's still not working
because
scroll time line
look it vanished there we go that's good
news and now it's growing there we go a
few little hiccups there but
everything's working uh except it's kind
of weird that it's growing from the
middle and not from the left so
kind of weird so let's come back to my
css and i guess i lied to you a little
bit uh and that we won't be writing any
just a little bit um let's just do a
transform
origin
of left
that should fix the whole problem and
that should give us there we go as we
scroll down it goes and when we reach
the bottom of the page it's full and
when we get to the top of the page uh we
don't have anything there and as i said
we can play around with some of the
numbers so maybe you'd have a footer and
you don't care about the footer in you
know so you could set this to 80 let's
just say
and then it will track it when you get
to 80 percent of the way down the page
it's showing that it's full and of
course you know you have something at
the top that you don't want it to count
so at the very beginning there's nothing
but then once i get past a certain point
that comes in or maybe you don't want
this as a percentage you can put that as
pixels and i could say 250 pixels and so
now it will only start once i get to 250
pixels it will start tracking so you
know you can even get javascript to get
the height of this and then use that as
the value that's coming in here whatever
you want i'm going to just do it for my
whole page so we'll leave that as a
percent
just like that all right and with that
done now let's see how we can take this
the next step and look at how we can
animate these images so we're not
watching the whole page but we're gonna
watch for the specific image locations
so the first thing we're going to do one
image first and then look at how we can
have it apply to as many as we want
and we're sort of exploring going to
explore different sort of properties and
different things that we can do with
this um as we go through on this one
so uh the first thing we're going to go
to my index and you can see i have this
image in here which has my image rotate
in class
so the first thing we should do is get
that image and so we're going to do a
const of we'll call it animated image is
going to be equal to
document.queryselector
and we'll choose that dot image rotate
rotate in
just like that
and so we've selected this image that's
right here and we do very similar we're
going to set up a timeline first and
then we're going to animate it
one big difference is what we're going
to do with our scroll offsets so let's
start by const and we'll call it
animated image
timeline
is equal to a new scroll timeline
and in this we're gonna have our we
don't need to have the source or the
orientation um as i said when we did
this these are defaults so i'm just
going to go in with my scroll offsets
and for the scroll offsets this time
we're actually going to do something a
little different like i said
and we're going to look at two different
approaches i'm going to look at the
first one which is going to watch the
image itself enter the viewport and
leave the viewport and that's actually
going to work a lot like how an
intersection observer works
which is probably the last time i talked
in depth about javascript but uh yeah
we're going to do that first and i'll
look at a limitation of that and then a
more involved solution that might be
closer to what you actually want to do
and so here on my scroll offsets what we
can do is we're going to open and close
some curly braces because what we can do
now is actually define a target so my
target in this case is going to be my
animated image
uh we're gonna have an edge and for now
just trust me on this one i'm gonna do
end and we're going to do a threshold
thresh hold
of 1 and i'm going to duplicate this
line here and don't worry i'm going to
explain it all more in a second we're
going to put a start here now what's
interesting about this is this is
actually when the animation will start
and this is when it's going to end so it
might seem a little bit strange having
the edge as a start and end
but trust me on it this is what we want
and as i said we'll explore this in a
little bit more detail and i just see a
syntax error here because i forgot my
my comma at the end of that line
so that should be enough as long as i
didn't make any other typos here and
actually i did these should be also
inside of quotation marks
uh so there we go we get my threshold of
one on both of those and thresholds a
scale of zero to one but we'll look at
that more but if you're used to
intersection observers that is uh you
you're probably familiar with that what
that is
and just like we need to set up our
scroll tracker animation here we're
gonna do the same thing here so we're
gonna do my animated image animate
open and close
our parentheses and then we can open and
close my curly braces and we're going to
do multiple different properties rather
than just one but we're going to start
with one and then add the other ones on
top
and the first thing is i'm going to do a
transform and we're going to go from a
rotate rotate
of x on the x-axis of 45 degrees which
is going to rotate the image this way
now for this on the transform we
actually need to do a bit more for it to
look good but i'll come back to that in
a second
so let's just see what this is going to
do first and then here rotate
to a zero and yeah that should work
perfectly
then let's come here and do a comma i
open it another set of curly braces and
my duration should be a1 and my timeline
in this case will be my image
uh what do we call it animated image
whoops animated
image
time line and so we should be able to
hit save on that oh i see something
changed to my image already so that's a
good sign and now as i scroll you can
see the image is sort of
unsquishing itself
which isn't exactly what we wanted but
at least it's doing something um
and so let's start with that and what
you'll notice it's not nothing's
happening and now all of a sudden it
starts and maybe we should do this even
more let's do 90 degrees
so or 180 so that should make it no 180
shouldn't yeah there we go a 90 makes it
vanish so it's completely flat and then
as we scroll up it's flattening itself
out and when the top of the image
reaches the top of the viewport it will
be completely done and to explain how
this is working i'm actually going to
bring in
this here which is a codepen i'll link
this in the description as well by
bramis
which
shows we have a starting edge and our
ending edge
so start we do start and then end and
then we have the threshold and a
threshold of 0 means the animation will
start when the element has touched the
ending edge or if we look at the
starting edge it's as soon as the
element has left completely the viewport
like as soon as it's touching the top of
the viewport but completely out
if we move this threshold you can see
how it's moving it into the viewport
which is sort of the blue area that we
have here and then when we get to here
that means when the threshold is one so
it's completely within the viewport and
it's touching the starting edge
and so what this is doing
so that's why we're having the animation
start at the ending edge because that's
the bottom of the viewport and we're
having the animation finish at the start
of our viewport which is at the very top
so it might sound a little strange but
it's sort of it makes sense when you
look at it that way so here if we
actually change this to a zero and a
zero
that means the animation is starting now
even though the image isn't on the
screen yet because it's you know it's
starting a little bit earlier and then
here it's finishing it's still animating
until it's all the way off the screen so
i think a lot of the time you probably
want a threshold of one though it's
possible you want something a little
different than that and so to improve
this a little bit what i'm going to do
is i'm going to come here and add
perspective perspective and i'm doing it
here i'm actually keeping my i'm going
to keep the perspective the same on both
of these so transform perspective and
this is just going to make it actually
look sort of 3d ish and this is a number
i find i just have to play with i'm not
very good at this
um so let's add a perspective there and
a perspective here
and so now you can see it actually gets
more of like this here it's completely
flat and you know it looks more like
you'd expect it to look right
for this type of thing so it's
completely linked to the scrolling of my
viewport which is cool now i think it's
a little too much
so let's i'm going to start it at 45. so
when it enters the viewport it's sort of
tilted a little bit as soon as it comes
in a bit more it starts tilting and then
it finishes at the top and to make it a
little bit nicer we have transform here
but we could also come in and say
opacity
and my opacity we could have it go from
a zero
to an opacity of one and so now if we
look at it it's completely gone and then
as i scroll the opacity will come in and
it will rotate up and yeah i just think
it looks a little bit nicer with the
opacity maybe you could actually start
it at like a 0.5 or something just so
it's not completely vanished when it
comes in it's a little bit there and
actually maybe here at the threshold of
zero
and this being at zero
could could potentially be better so
it's starting to fade in as soon as it
enters the viewport but then it's
completely in view and completely
finished by the time it reaches the top
of the viewport now what you might
actually like is that it's completely
finished the animation here but before
we worry about that let's see how we
could actually get this to work over
multiple images and i'm not saying this
is the animation that you'd necessarily
want to do over multiple images now
luckily to do that it's actually really
easy
it's just here let's come up and here i
have my animated image let's make this
plural so it's a bit better and here i'm
going to do a query selector all so it's
selecting all of my images with that
class which i have this one and there is
a another one here so we have my two
identical images in this case
um and this will also show us a little
bit of a limitation of the scroll
timeline here that we have but
i'll get to that in a second
but basically everything here can stay
exactly the same the only difference is
right here
so the first thing we're going to do is
let's say my animated images
and we need to say for each
and for each one of the image image for
each image inside of my animated images
we want to do something so we'll throw
an arrow function in here
and let's there we go perfect and now
what i'm going to do is i'm just going
to grab this here and drop it right in
here but instead of my animated image
here and then i can bring each one of
those down right here
i'm just going to save to format the
code a little bit better
and i'm just going to then take all of
this and
take all of that
and i'll show you actually we're going
to let's take all of this first and just
to make this actually work we can bring
it all into here
and now it should work for both of my
images and
here we also this one just i had that as
animated image before so we just want to
actually remove all of that and make
that my image as well
so for each image we're going to have
this animation running that's using this
scroll timeline right here
uh and the only reason that i'm putting
this inside the for each here is just so
the target is it's creating a new target
for all of the images that are getting
that class and now we can see that it's
working for both of those images so as i
go down there's one there's the other
one perfect now one thing you could do
if you don't like this idea of having
this here and having this here is we
could actually take all of this where it
says new scroll timeline and select all
of that
and so let's take that and i'm going to
comment out this entire section and then
when we have a timeline here instead of
looking back at that timeline we can
actually put all of that here where you
actually just make a new timeline right
there so if i hit save now it's still
working just as it was before it's
exactly the same thing that we just had
so if we you know you don't have too
much going on over here it could be a
simpler way to do it the nice thing with
having these is sometimes you'll have
multiple different objects using or
sharing one timeline so having this on
its own here lets you point multiple
different things at it whereas in this
situation it's very stuck to being only
for the image and that's it and as i
said there's one more thing which is
we don't always want it to start here
maybe i only want the animation to start
once we're past this threshold of one or
we want it to finish before we're at
this threshold of one over here and with
the threshold we can't actually do that
so i'm going to comment out these scroll
offsets here and i'm going to bring in a
our very new scroll offsets um and it's
going to take a little bit of a similar
approach
than we did here with our css
percentages but it's going to be a
little bit more complex
um so actually the first thing for each
one of these images we are going to get
something um so what i'm going to do is
create a new variable here called image
offset top and sometimes i get questions
on here conster let
const works because it's doing it for
each image
individually so it can be a cons it
doesn't get redefined anywhere and so
for that my image offset top is going to
be equal to the image and we can just do
an offset top
and
then i'm also gonna do a const of image
height and that's going to be equal to
my offset height
just like that
uh so that should give me those values
for both images that we have and as i
said that's just because we're going to
use these in a bit of a different way so
here what what i want to do is i'm
actually going to say that the first
offset we're going to do a css pixel but
we're going to use all of these so we
want to get my image offset top plus my
image height
and we're going to do those together
minus
my win
uh window dot inner
height
and so that's where the start and i'll
explain this in a second and let's just
put a comma here and then the second one
is going to be a css pixel as well and
for this one i'm just going to say my
image offset top
and we're going to change these in a
second but that should work there we go
so you can see that's working and okay
let's explain what this is doing
so we're saying my image offset top so
how far the image is from the very
top of the viewport so from here
all the way down to the top of the image
is this
this one right here
then we're adding my image height to it
um actually what i mean if we didn't do
it with the image height here would be
the same as having a threshold of zero
it would kick in as soon as the image uh
is at the very bottom whereas now what
i've done is pretty much replicated this
idea of a threshold of one as soon as
the entire image has entered the
viewport it's going to start and then
here the offset image offset top is the
same thing that we had right here so you
might be saying kevin you just did a
whole bunch of stuff to replicate what
we had here and i did it's true but the
the one advantage we have here is then
you could throw extra numbers in here so
for example if i wanted it to end 200
pixels before the top i could just do a
minus 200. so let's hit save on that and
now we'll see the animation is
completely done here
so we're not getting to the threshold of
one we're getting to a threshold of like
minus 200 and then we can do that same
thing over here i don't know if this
would be a plus or a minus let's try
plus 200
and let's just see
yeah so now it's getting it's doing
nothing and then once we're 200 pixels
past the entire image the bottom the
image is 200 pixels away from the bottom
then it's going to start that animation
and so it's not perfect by any means i
don't think i necessarily want it to
start there so even you can have it
start before it even enters the viewport
with a minus there so it's starting it's
already going and then it's finished
before we get to there and maybe we'll
make that a minus
so that way you sort of get the in
instead of having to wait until in this
case we're revealing it at the very top
we're allowing it to happen much much
sooner and so just a couple of ideas
there that you could do but this does
show the one other limitation of this is
as i scroll back and forth it's always
running the animation and that could be
a little bit annoying you might want
this to you know if you're doing it for
certain reveals it could be a nice thing
or if you're doing it for your tracker
up here it could be a good thing if
you're doing this for image things that
slide in and then they're sliding in and
then somebody scrolls up and they slide
away and they slide back in and they
slide away and that could actually be
kind of annoying and you don't
necessarily want to be linking the
sliding in animation to the scrolling
itself like we are here like this is
kind of cool because it's really linked
to that because the rotation of the
image is based on that that might be
something you want if you just want
something to appear on the screen once
it gets to the right place that's where
an intersection observer would come in
and if you'd like to know more about
intersection observers or you'd like to
know how this is all going to work with
css only because this will be a css only
thing at one point once browser support
gets there well i've looked at both of
those and you can see those videos right
here and with that i want to say a
really big thank you to my supporters of
awesome over on patreon jan johnny
stewart tim and simon as well as all my
other patrons for their monthly support
and of course until next time don't
forget to make your core on the internet
just a little bit more awesome